pour fêter fait qu'on soit déjà plus de
100 milles dans la grande famille des tc
je vous avais proposé une petite faq
vous m'avez envoyé énormément de
questions et encore plein de messages
super sympa merci beaucoup
maintenant c'est à moi de bosser à
l'éphédrine question qui revient très
souvent alors on va commencer par là
comme ça ce sera fait et tu médecin
voilà j'ai cru comprendre que tu étais
infirmiers dans quel service as tu
bosses et je l'exercé en tant
qu'infirmier pendant plus de dix ans
principalement en réanimation et au smur
ou samu si vous préférez après j'ai
travaillé en libéral c'est à dire que
j'allais soigner les gens chez eux et
puis j'ai fait aussi du coaching santé
c'est à dire de l'éducation par
téléphone voilà ça c'est pour les
grandes lignes mais j'ai aussi travaillé
aux urgences en chirurgie en salle de
réveil au bloc opératoire et c'est
pourquoi as-tu arrêté alors j'ai adoré
mais j'ai arrêté parce que j'avais envie
de voir autre chose du coup je suis
devenu journaliste pendant huit ans et
puis l'a récemment j'ai encore eu envie
de voir autre chose et voilà comment en
es tu arrivé à faire des vidéos sur
youtube
j'ai commencé à faire des vidéos dans le
cadre de mon métier de journaliste que
j'ai finalement quitté pour plus faire
que ça pour lancer ma chaîne youtube
j'ai choisi la santé assez logiquement
parce que c'est un sujet que je maîtrise
et que j'ai pu voir pendant les lie des
nues original que c'est quelque chose
qui vous plaît pas mal et tu une
saucisse oui les solstices ont su qu'un
jour tu ne risque pas d'avoir totalement
épuisé ton sujet sur le corps humain
non parce que je pense que c'est un
sujet inépuisable et en plus comme j'ai
envie de traiter tous types de sujets
sur la santé c'est encore plus
inépuisable qui est un truc déjà il
accusa donc c'est complètement
inépuisable ok les crottes de nez ça se
mange mais le caca comment as tu connu
cyprien on a travaillé ensemble chez 20
minutes donc on s'est connu là bas lui
l'aluminé mission qui s'appelle rewind à
laquelle je participais tous les joueurs
avec déjà là me romain à la caméra au
montage et on blague
est-ce que romain s'occupe également de
la caméra et du son et des cuirs les
scripts des décès avec toi ou le fait
tout seul j'écrirai vidéo et roman
s'occupe de tout le reste c'est à dire
la caméra le montage les effets spéciaux
etc vont nous voir le fameux renard un
jour
non parce qu'il y beaucoup trop bouger
pornic
on a un misterobert nous c'est un
homonyme moins bien joué charlotte ouais
on m'invite cielo a bien été élu mister
auvergne en 2014
mais tu sais quoi la main chacune un nom
c'est quoi ça bon d'accord j'arrête
merci pour moi tu seras toujours mr bern
comment as tu trouvé ce titre de chaîne
youtube au début cherché un nom avec
santé dedans mais tombée que sur des
jeux de mots pourris dtcc a même failli
s'appeler santé moi ça du coup après
j'ai cherché avec le mot corps et j'ai
choisi dans ton corps parce que je
trouvais que détesté ça claquait bien
que savait jamais utilisé aixam
n'évoquait absolument rien de grave le
saucisson ou sada me soit 6 combien de
temps tu mets en tout par semaine pour
faire une vidéo et as tu d'autres jobs
pour combler les trous des fins de mois
mais deux ou trois jours avec les une
vidéo de a à z et on tourne en une
demi-journée avec romain
le reste du temps j'écris aussi des
sketches pour louer vous pour la télé et
à l'occasion quand on m'appelle je joue
dans des sketches des clips des vidéos
comme dans l'excellentissime court
métrage de rappel des cracks submission
skweres par exemple c'est bien toi qui
joues leurs balises dans game of thrones
ce qui t'arrive souvent de tuer des gens
pour disséquer leur cerveau on parlait
de la vidéo sur la gueule de bois c'est
ça bah non c'est une cervelle d'agneau
battu parler des femmes
pas forcément des règles bien sûr j'en
parle déjà en fait que les sujets dont
je parle dans dtcc a concerné deux sexes
mais m'ont promis je ferai aussi des
vidéos sur des sujets exclusivement
fémur c'est bien toi qui étais dans le
rewind avant si c'est le cas je me
souviens d'un moment où tu bouges est et
narines juste devant la caméra et ça
m'avait fait marrer je sais pas pourquoi
c'est dangereux de se masturber bah
écoutes je te réponds la semaine
prochaine on était d'accord
as tu d'autres projets pour ta chaine
websérie interviews etc
j'ai plein de projets pour ma chaîne
j'aimerais bien avoir plusieurs formats
dans lesquels je pourrais piocher en
fonction du sujet peut-être avec des
invités on verra dans tout ça c'est
encore un petit peu tôt c'est tout frais
ici encore et en dehors de dtc je vais
aussi bien envie de faire de la fiction
ce soir en tant qu'auteur ou en tant que
comédien comment agrandir la taille de
son pénis
chacun va trouver si tu devais faire un
top 5 des groupes de métal tu dirais qui
tu te rendras compte que c'est super dur
ce que tu me demandes mais je dirais
tous adultes à 9,6 sepultura metallica
moto raid est allé madball et c'est
vraiment dur pourquoi il ya du sang sur
tes chaussures une sale histoire de chin
beaucoup trop épicé
quand tu repères mon internet à noir
pour ceux qui connaissent pas mon
internet à moi c'est une série
d'interviews de créateurs vidéaste et
youtube heures que j'ai fait
et oui j'aimerais beaucoup recommencer
tas d'autres styles de musique que tu m
as par le rock et le métal
j'ai longtemps écouté que du métal et
puis j'ai découvert public enemy grâce à
l'anthrax qui rogne m6 grâce aerosmith
et je me suis mis à aimer grave
et puis après j'ai découvert plein
d'autres styles musicaux et monuments ça
provoque un truc en moi j'écoute je me
pose plus de questions mais le métal
savoir une place à part tu pourras faire
une vidéo avec adrien où vous racontez
vos dossiers d'enfants
j'adorerais tourner avec mon frère et
j'espère vraiment que ça va se faire un
jour mais pas forcément pour raconter
des dossiers d'enfants
pourquoi tu as une petite [ __ ] un peu
froid
il est gentil wax lama figurez-vous
qu'en plus d'être extrêmement
talentueuse d'avoir des goûts musicaux
très sûr et d'être atrocement bg watts
et terriblement gentil de mecs énervant
non en vrai je le remercierai jamais
assez d'avoir composé juste pour moi le
générique de dtc que j'adore merci aux
enfants comment être sexy et séduisant
et là il suffit de télécharger et
d'imprimer ceux ci et de son faire un
masque et hop ils feront berd erik xiv
merci qui comment s'appelle le squelette
derrière toi c'est une bonne question ça
y'a pas de nom en fait à les commander
une grande famille on va tout choisir
ensemble le mettre vos propositions dans
les commentaires hockey quels insectes
pourrais tu manges et en fait des
insectes j'en ai déjà mangé pas mal quel
est ton plat préféré le rougail saucisse
c'est plus qu'on sente à blues à bonne
question
bah écoute on va voir ça tout de suite
quand je suis content je vous me away
quelles sont les particularités moi par
exemple j'ai une jambe un peu plus
courte que l'autre
alors je me suis fait casser le nez
quatre fois et je suis daltonien
c'est pour ça que j'invite tout le temps
tout en noir comme sa chaussure de
canard de l harmonie de couleurs
quel sport pratiquer tu joue au rugby
c'est pour ça que je le mets travers dix
nous une anecdote sur toi j'ai fait du
poney avec tonton david ya eu aussi
beaucoup de questions un peu plus
personnel donc pour finir on va faire un
instant livret de famille qui est la
fille que tu embrasses dans la vidéo
être sale c'est bon pour la santé
c'est la jeune femme qui partage ma vie
tout simplement tu es en couple avec
sophie riches
ouais voilà on peut rien vous cacher la
jeune femme que j'embrasse goulûment
dans la vidéo et qui partage ma vie
c'est sophie riche la fameuse chauffage
je ressemble beaucoup à norman tu serais
pas son frère par hasard des frères de
nicolas berneau a tout fait penser aux
types de golden moustache tu serais pas
le frère de flaubert non j'ai un père
génial c'est vrai c'est aucun de ceux-là
draper est ce que tu es advient meyniel
parce que tu le ressens quand même
beaucoup à alors non je suis pas adrien
meyniel je suis julien ménielle c'est
normal qu'on se ressemble beaucoup parce
qu'on a pas mal d'à dna comment dans la
mesure où on a les mêmes parents et mon
frère en fait c'est mon petit frère
mais bon si vous regardez bien on n'a
pas la même couleur de cheveux on n'a
pas la même couleur d'yeux et ont fait
pas la même taille en plus je suis plus
grand donc non on n'est pas la même
personne et sa vallée bonne forme depuis
le début d'un truc
voilà cette faq est maintenant terminée
on se retrouve mercredi prochain à 18h
pour une nouvelle vidéo ici la forte
midi